are you playing a lot of guitar these
days yeah I have been playing I like the
last three or four days I'm like what do
I do
oh yeah I play guitar yeah let's try
something I like to say it my way which
is there's a line on down the road you
know what I also say I used to think for
years that when Van Morrison said going
down to the old mine with a transistor
radio I used to think he was saying
going down on an old man for a
transistor radio and hacks like that
must have been some great anyway and
listening to a lot of music in the house
you - oh no not a lot of music screening
a ton of movies making my kids watch all
the Pink Panther movies with Peter
Sellers
we're gonna watch Young Frankenstein
right yes I couldn't get a cook and I my
thing again I don't know what the hell's
going on and anyways I ended up from
Young Frankenstein putting on young
Lincoln old Henry Fonda movie you
watching any of your movies with the
kids this is a good time to make them
watch your stuff yes now we've we've
been watching all of my stuff in there
ranking at all and you know what I yeah
my kids they literally and everyone I've
done is incredible so you can't write my
niece just had a baby two days
your niece had a baby that's great
that's fantastic little summer little
summer and a family way to go guys and
thanks to the staff at the hospital the
taking care of everybody and making sure
you know the corona of it all everybody
was nervous about that but everything's
good and healthy and way to go way to go
guys nice Dube we're lucky that we live
at a time when you and I can get on the
computer and talk like this if this had
happened you know whatever 10 15 years
ago
I'd have to sneak into your house to
come talk to you I know I wouldn't I get
in my legs would be in the house 20
minutes before I was it'd come in like
snakes you'd see legs freckled legs
coming in for 20 minutes you'd be like
Hornets coming let's let's stay strong
he does wash them hands like everybody's
saying to do yeah follow the rules and
everyone says the same thing which is
act as if you have the virus so stay
away from people and this too shall pass
so try and remain optimistic Adam I love
you take care of yourself everybody yeah
and thank you for spreading some good
cheer that's a nice thing see y'all food
all right we'll see you later bike